Sheetal: Hi! My name is Shepherd, and I am an accessible
Sheetal: today. I'm going to explore a fables Upskill Demo page on my windows, laptop, and i'll be using chrome as the browser.
I'm using zoom text fusion as my assistive technology.
Sheetal: And
Sheetal: before I I I start with my task, which is exploring the page. I need to explore the content on the demo page, and maybe just go through some some activities and see how can how I can navigate through different activities
Sheetal: on that page. I'm not still logged in, so I will log in, and I will talk about my experience as I move on on the page.
Sheetal: So before that just wanted to talk a little bit about the the system technology which i'm gonna use today. So i'm gonna use zoom text fusion. which is, which uses where where I use both the zoom text magnification, feature as well as the reader. So, as I move along, I will be talking about my experience, using both the screen manification
Sheetal: and and and and reading the content as depending on how much content I have on the page so quickly. I am on the
Sheetal: the login page right now. I'll just try. I'll log in and then let's see how the the page is laid out. So
Sheetal: Login Page again looks quite simple.
Sheetal: I have not magnified my screen yet. but the contrast is great for me, and the form fields are are.
Sheetal: or you know, Good sized so I can.
Sheetal: I'm able to
Sheetal: log in even
Sheetal: without magnifying. But here, yes, for for typing the password. I'll be zooming in just trying to to zoom, and manually in order to to show the magnification level I I have to use while i'm typing the password
Sheetal: A.
Sheetal: Then I like the feature that I can
hey?
4,
one
Sheetal: just log in
4 one.
Sheetal: So i'm on the home page right now. So, as I said, login was was
Sheetal: quite accessible for me. A big form feels just for the password. I'm 3. I just zoom in. Otherwise I have a good. So whenever I have to put in the credentials. I just zoom this screen. So just to make sure I have typed the right credentials. So this brings me to the homepage
again. Pictures nice and big.
Sheetal: The text boxes are are nicely demarcated. So
Sheetal: just looking at the overall web page before I start exploring it.
Sheetal: so I can see the courses which are available to me.
4.
Sheetal: I don't need that much magnification. 1.4 1.2 making on the first course available.
One.
Sheetal: it's called testing accessibility. So let's that. That is
Sheetal: forest details.
Sheetal: As I said, I usually use a mix of screen magnification and screen reader because I with my vision. I am still I unable to read, but then it's. Sometimes it comes to tiring for my eyes, so I rely on greedo as well.
Sheetal: Let's start first, and then i'll just turn on the reader. And just to show
Sheetal: activity, I I need to explore the activities i'm just trying to see where I can find the activities here.
Sheetal: I can see
Sheetal: the available available in the demo.
I have been
Sheetal: I to explore these
Sheetal: because all these I think they they
Sheetal: being disabled, so I can't use them. So I see the link here.
Sheetal: I just try to go in this one.
Sheetal: So this brings me to the course which says Automated accessibility testing. Again.
Sheetal: I I feel good contrast. I really like the layout of the page. The design is simple.
Sheetal: On On the on the left side of the screen. I can see all the
Sheetal: the the course outline.
Sheetal: then quite excellent, so so nothing much to an under it. I can see.
Sheetal: I will find activities done.
Sheetal: Then it also gives me an idea about how many activities are there, and how many I have completed.
Sheetal: And also, I think this shows me
which one I am right now.
Sheetal: Hmm.
Sheetal: So here, as the kind of content of the pages more it is here when I start using my reader.
Sheetal: The the reading feature of the zoom text
skip to main content courses.
breadcrum courses, testing accessibility, automated accessibility, testing automated accessibility, testing side menu course outline skip to activity, testing accessibility, testing 5 5 5 activities done automated accessibility testing 3. S0 6 activities done automating accessibility, testing browser extensions, content editing tool Ci and testing frameworks react jest Moca Linters react
automated testing quiz manual accessibility, testing 7 7 activities done documenting accessibility errors, 5 5 active
Sheetal: Okay. So
Sheetal: this is usually how how I use it. So the reader will just read, and I keep following the red box, so I know where I am, and then I don't have to use or strain my eyes to to read the content which is really helpful, and it just increases my speed, and makes me more efficient.
So, coming back to the magnification 1.2
Sheetal: again. I can see the headings are nice and big
Sheetal: again. Great contrast! I can see the difference. Different links which are available.
Sheetal: So this one is on
Sheetal: using automated. Okay. So this one is about automated testing.
Sheetal: I'm: just trying to go through a little.
Sheetal: So here I just want to tell you what what magnification level I am, just to give you an idea.
One 1.2,
Sheetal: 1.4 1 1.8,
2,
Sheetal: 2.2 5,
Sheetal: so i'm at a magnification of 2.2 5
Sheetal: again, the magnification level. Naturally for headings the level is less; but as the content
it is of different sizes, so I always have to keep increasing and increasing the magnification, while i'm going through the
Sheetal: through through any content on the page.
2.5.
Sheetal: I think this one is is comfortable for me to read.
Sheetal: and I see there is table here which says 2 barriers.
Sheetal: all links in the next below.
Sheetal: So this is a this.
Sheetal: This is nice, because it it just gives me a heads up that these will open new terms, and I I really like the list
Sheetal: of automated tools which are available.
Sheetal: Hmm.
One.
2, point 5,
one.
2, point 5.
Sheetal: Why.
Sheetal: I see the next activity. Tab, I really like
Sheetal: Oh. that one! As As soon as I hubble my mouse on it, it changes.
Sheetal: It changes the color which just helps relocate my mouse, because many times I lose that as well.
Sheetal: Okay. So I am on the next activity. Now 2.5.
Sheetal: I'm. Still at the magnification. 2.5, I think I 2.7 3, 3, point 5. But again, contrast is good, but I always try to keep the magnification more, so that I don't have to.
Sheetal: you know. Be very close to the screen in order to read it. I can see there is a video here that's late.
Sheetal: I'm. Just trying to interact with different elements which are there on the screen. Hi! This is Kate and I'm going to show you how to use the wave browser extension by web, a. To check the accessibility of a website. This is a free browser extension.
Sheetal: A. On like
3.5.
Sheetal: Why just made this full screen
Sheetal: easy.
3.5.
Sheetal: What we do is nice and clear. 3.5.
Sheetal: Oh.
Sheetal: one, yeah.
3.5.
Sheetal: Well, I I noticed that these icons are not labeled, I think yet, because I think that
Sheetal: sometimes I I don't, you know.
Sheetal: Look at the the label. I don't look at the icons. I just do go with the with the the label which appears when I brow by, when I just cover my mouse on it. So I think that if if if that is added, it would be great
Sheetal: or
Sheetal: yeah.
Sheetal: 3.5,
then we have the video transcript. I really like this feature of your transcript
Sheetal: one.
Sheetal: because sometimes the content is somebody you know is is speaking maybe a little fast for me, and if I try to read the captions. They they just come and go so quickly. So i'm not able to understand.
So given you getting the option of being able to read the transcript at my pace. Really, as we understand the content better.
Sheetal: he said, this describes the video, and then we have another demo. the X E.
Sheetal: I'm. Looking on it.
Hello, it's Kate again, and we are going to test the same website using a different accessibility tool. This time we're going to use the axe browser extension. It's made by a company called Dq. And it's available for chrome firepox. And
Sheetal: yeah, I really like these videos, because I've heard about these extensions. But I don't know how to use them. So this you know, I'm. I'm really excited to to explore these actually in in at some point of time.
Sheetal: because these would really help understand how these extensions can be used quickly. Going to the next activity. 3.5,
Sheetal: one with one more.
Sheetal: I don't know if it's my
one.
Sheetal: my laptop as well. Today I'll just go back to the course and see if I can just
Sheetal: navigate the list there.
Sheetal: Going back to the list.
3.5.
Sheetal: Well, I can see all the activities which which I can which are available on this page.
Sheetal: Nineers.
Sheetal: Okay, let's. I see this quiz if I can just quickly
Sheetal: again all the tabs. They are quite interactive
Sheetal: so quickly, you know, even without using the magnification, I come to know that this is a clickable link which which is really helpful.
3.5,
One.
Sheetal: Yeah. I'll just randomly click. Okay?
Sheetal: Oh, as soon as I click. I I really like this
Sheetal: a feature of
Sheetal: the choice becoming, you know
Sheetal: again, a good clue for my I that I just selected, that I just go to the next one and see what's happening.
One.
Sheetal: Hi. So again, I really like the design simple design of it, though i'm on this
Sheetal: page for the first time.
Sheetal: But you know I am able to interact with with all the elements and understand how I can navigate through the course.
Sheetal: I just go back to the close, so I believe I was able to complete the task of
Sheetal: getting to the web page logging in and then
trying to just navigate through different
Sheetal: demo activities which are available on the page, I was able to navigate from one actually to the next.
Sheetal: So it was. The instructions were easy to understand.
Sheetal: and the contrast work great for me. I have to magnify the screen, which you know
Sheetal: because of you know the size of the content. But I think that doesn't matter, because with the great contrast, I still don't have to magnify a lot.
Sheetal: which, if the contrast was not good, I really have to go to to
Sheetal: to a higher magnification level. So I really you know it. It worked for me
Sheetal: overall. I find that the page is is very accessible and easy to use, and in your future I would really like to explore it.
Sheetal: Thank you so much for listening to me today.